mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
gehört werden und eine stimme haben
die so viel gekämpft und geopfert haben
für gleichheit freiheit gerechtigkeit
für alle von laut starken frauen und 50
jahren frauenstimmrecht
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz ja daran
kommen wir nicht vorbei es gibt in der
tat nur wenige länder die sich mit der
einführung des frauenstimmrechts noch
schwerer taten aus mir
wieso das bei uns so ewig gedauert hat
wie es heute aussieht in sachen
weiblichkeit und politik und welcher
starken frauen uns in diesen tagen
inspirierend dazu unsere seine heute
[Musik]
und das beste an was einem häuser birgit
steinegger ist sogar hallo wie granit
als verwalter cds glaube du hast so
viele politikerinnen über so viele jahre
produziert hat dann so oft wie das
lieblingsopfer dir überall die ja das
ist nicht wenig tragen sie natürlich
besser schlagen als die anderen
die parodie der sich noch gut dass ich
allerdings im radio ob sie also noch mal
mehr braucht das ist elisabeth kopp sie
die an erspartem fertig gemacht und nach
und ja so viele als ich nachfragte und
japanischen oxid eshop frau magdalena
das lustig und jetzt gehen wir zusammen
darum historische museum bayern pro jahr
zu ist für neues machen und mir werden
dass das jetzt sagen die umstellung der
frauen ins bundeshaus
in der ausstellung erzählen schweizer
politikerinnen der ersten stunde ganz
persönlich von ihren erfahrungen von den
kämpfen errungenschaften und vor allem
von den schwierigkeiten aus frauen in
komplett männerdominierten bundeshaus
schlimmste von risikoposten die warme
helmut gesetz ausgelöst aus die ganze
positiver fußballs
ich glaube für meine kollegen noch etwas
ziemlich exotisch würde mich hier jetzt
50 jahre frauenstimmrecht aber das mit
dem 4
das ist ein schlechter witz ja findet so
wirklich schlecht ich erinnere an
siebter februar und in seine service für
das frauenstimmrecht xj ist ja denn nach
dem seminar und der schauspielschule in
paris image der engagement nach biel
solothurn bisher eher unsicherer mensch
ja immer als großes
gerechtigkeitsempfinden bist du damals
als junge frau ein politischer mensch
die politik hat mir aber nicht gross
interessiert die besucher selber
beschäftigen sie aber er versucht durch
mini betreten
dies bewirke mit dem monet einigermaßen
hat zum beispiel mit polit parade
dort probierte die sachen oft stecken
aber natürliche bescheidenem rahmen
es freut mich dass ich da noch zu wort
kommen
[Musik]
das merci mischling du bist vor der
schauspielerei zu der parodie wir gott
partie überhaupt finde man darf nicht
grob werden es darf nicht verletzend sie
sich immer eine gratwanderung wie darf
ich natürlich wünscht du dir dann im
leben gemacht machen die immer nur
sondern nationalratsdebatte zu folgen
ist für mich fest mährischen simmons
alex nicht verletzt es darf nicht grob
sie und muss immer noch wie sie der
bundesrat ist der meinung dass er die
meinung vertreten
also ich meine wir meinen das team ein
mut machendes der hand dass probleme der
fraktionen diskutiert und dann in der
kommission mit rita zu 0 stimmen
beschlossen das mir durch ruß
humorverständnis gabuns elwy okaz ihre
hoheit tablet danny macht googles
du hast ich habe schon sehr exponiert
aus person hast du dich exponiert mit
einer serie und das hat ihnen aber ein
wahnsinniger schöne geschichte lebt im
zusammenhang mit der frau alt
bundesrätin ruth dreifuss und ihr bin
ich aus drei fuß trat ich habe vertrag
halten als ruth dreifuss und die akkus
dass die richtige frau dreyfus im saal
sitzt hans peter goetz und nach dem
ausfall dreyfus katie ein gestocher
schauspiel und rinder die bildstelle
gericht doch global insight
das wäre schön wenn ja ob daraus nicht
die beleidiger wenn man sie parodieren
rückschlag wenn sie dort wenn sie hat
die beliebige partikel parodiert sind
mithin und kurve politikerin mit wahrer
größe wasser in kommt für sie
vorgängerin aus dem hintergrund für das
thema vorstellen wieso salon gekommen
ist bis wieder stimmrecht kann das zeigt
jetzt ein blick sicht
die schweizer frauen teilen vor
wahllokalen das schicksal mit den hunden
die schweiz ist die älteste demokratie
das wort demokratie heißt aber
herrschaft des volkes und mir scheint
dass die frauen auch zum folgt gehören
die frau gehört ins haus die wende ist
einfach 100 jahre lang kämpften
schweizer frauen für politisches
mitspracherecht in der direkten
demokratie waren sie den männlichen
stimmbürgern auf gedeih und verderb
ausgeliefert
erst 1971 wurde aus einem kategorischen
nein ein jahr
doch bis heute bringen frauen wie flavia
kleiner historikerin und co initianten
der kampagne helvetia ruft um eine
ausgeglichene geschlechterverteilung in
parlamenten und regierungen
idee und der demokratie ist immer das
eigene ist bevölkerung so wie sie ist so
unterschiedlich wie sich so verschiedene
sichtweisen und in trance wie sie hat
vertraten nicht doch der reihe nach mit
der bundesverfassung von 1848 wird das
allgemeine stimm und wahlrecht
eingeführt
für männer
das ist unglaublich cool und progressiv
aber mit emanzipation der frauen hat
sich fast nicht nur dritte
schon mitte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
schließen sich frauen zusammen und
wehren sich gegen die diskriminierung
[Musik]
richtig laut wird die forderung 1918 im
ersten weltkrieg haben sich die frauen
an der heimatfront stark gemacht und
erwarten nun wertschätzung
in deutschland und österreich wird das
frauenwahlrecht eingeführt
doch in der schweiz erzielt selbst der
dreitägige landes streikt diesbezüglich
nichts
zehn jahre später kein bisschen
fortschritt in bern spricht im
eröffnungszug der weltweit ersten
ausstellung für frauenarbeit dieses
symbol bände die frauen geben gas und
los ihre 1929 eine petition achtlose
kunde schriftform anna und 170
unterschriften für frauen mit 250 bis 1
54 millionen geschätzt man hat das am
bundesrat 3 6 erstmals konnte erstmals
an die urne gebeten werden
schweizerinnen anfang der 50er jahre
allerdings nur um zu bekunden ob sie auf
kantons- und gemeindeebene tatsächlich
würden mitbestimmen wollen
für diesmal bleiben sie draußen die
rechte sind heute für madame ihnen
bleiben die pflichten
[Musik]
sie gibt sich gerichte können
und du weißt bei trauma stimme da hat
doch kein wetter mache doch als er im
anlegerrecht nicht alle frauen wurden
mitbestimmen wollen aber die meisten
1957 wirbelt ein walliser bergdorf
kräftig staub auf zum allerersten mal
stimmen frauen ab naja die stimmen
werden letztlich nicht gezählt aber
journalisten aus der ganzen welt reisen
an
dorfbewohner zivile von kanton und die
wähler von bundesbahn
das brachte donnerkeil kann man sagen
ich habe es geliebt
manche bewegt ein jahr darauf sagen
national und ständerat ja zum
eidgenössischen von stimm und wahlrecht
die frauen könnten jubeln wäre die
schweiz eben keine direkte demokratie
denn die verfassungsrevision muss vors
stimmvolk die männer teile der vorlage
am ersten februar 1959 eine schallende
ohrfeige
stillstand
ohnmacht
an diesem schwarzen tag erinnern in den
folgejahren fackelzüge
doch dann in den 60ern kommt bewegung in
die sache
die neue frauenbewegung hat genug von
schweigemärschen aufklärungsarbeit
galanterie und diplomatie und fordert
lauthals taten mehr als 5000 frauen und
männer
angeführt von der ersten zürcher
stadträtin emilie lieberherr maschine
1969 in bern auf obwohl die schweiz den
frauen nach wie vor ein grundrecht
verweigert drängt der bundesrat darauf
die europäische menschenrechtskonvention
zu unterzeichnen
das ist auch politisch zum st die wand
wann mannschaft ohne fracht nach
hundertjährigen ringen wird das
eidgenössische frauen stimm und
wahlrecht am 17 februar 1971 angenommen
mit einer zweidrittelmehrheit und flavia
kleiner wie sieht es heute aus mit
politischer gleichstellung und ich
glaube frauen geschichtsschreiber
demokratiegeschichte und sogar europa
geschäft schrieb mir eines tages erste
land sind somit 50 prozent frauen im
parlament vertreten ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er gibt dem urteil ist ratings sie und
data hat zwar stehen 18 10 uhr
wie hat sie das empfunden sie kaum
vorstellbar für sie ist dass er forscht
sie dass sie bestimmen und war gleich
aggressiv sehr selbständig geflogen die
studie bildet lehrer kennen die beiden
schweizer familie gründet und mutter
geschafft also für sie ist es
selbstverständlich sein abstand und
hinterfuß gleichberechtigung selbst
endlich krieg sie sich als sehr
politisch bedeutsamen moment mit die
zeichnung ist wichtig für dich ist die
ware nicht wahr
das ist übrigens steht an dieser
protestaktion vor der frage stand oder
sp wo er den programmes portiert und die
stadt gefällt wurde und dort ist es für
mich spannend direkt in das gehege mit
dem politischen stimmung wurde
ich wurde von bürgerlicher seite darauf
hingewiesen dass ich für eine bundesrat
die ungeeignet ausgerüstet sein
du bist als role model und zu rang eins
gesehen nämlich durch eine von der erste
frau in der schweiz überhaupt getraut
hat lustig zu
juni wird sich das ist verständlich
keine damals möglichst das gelieferte ja
das ist irgendwie war sie noch so lustig
sie hätten oder fragfinn.de froh sie
nicht weniger lustig auswahl
aber das problem ist dass jedermann weiß
was lustig ist und hätte man besser bis
anders und durch den acht treffer
das ist glück noch nie hey kopf wenn man
das gelungen ist wunderbares geschenk
risiken durch durch ständig schlagen
das nachher wieder okay
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
doch da
unser heutiger kultur kick wettbewerb
ist auch komplett weiblich wir stellen
ihnen zwei autorinnen vor die sind ganz
besonders miteinander verbandelt als
mutter und tochter nämlich stefanie
group und ihre 13 jährige tochter
annalena
beide haben sie im letzten jahr fast
zeitgleich ein buch herausgegeben das
autorenduo voll im schuss eigentlich
doch corona hat auch die beiden tüchtig
ausgebremst
[Musik]
es ist wirklich die buchhandlung und
ruhm ist handlicher zurück sie gekostet
es wird wieder und tochter mehr leiter
für sie dürfte hier gelassen auf die
hier gelassen und wie ihre nachricht die
absage
zwei jahre lang hat hanna linhe an ihrer
geschichte von katze moni und fährt luna
die nach den sternen greifen geschrieben
als sie damit begann war sie gerade mal
[Musik]
und so will ich das buch hat ganz ohne
zutun der eltern ein seriöser verlag
herausgegeben
das ist schweizweit einzigartig ihre
lehrerin hat die geschichte eingereicht
und so wurde hannah lin unverhofft zur
verlegten jung autorin
ein bisschen weniger fantasy ein
bisschen mehr realität will herrn all-in
nun in ihrem zweiten buch haben die lust
am schreiben die wurde ihr wie heißt es
so schön in die wiege gelegt denn ihre
beiden eltern sind autoren auch vater
gerhard meister
so wundert es nicht ist der fünfköpfige
familien alltag gespickt mit
sprachspielen und punkten im autoren
familien kleinunternehmen leben zu
pandemie zeiten helfen alle mit den
kamera ausschnitt aufbrezeln zum
beispiel die verbliebenen lesungen sind
ins internet verlegt die auftritte im
theater vertagt
doch proben für ein neues stück auf
unbestimmte zeit verschoben
tun sie trotzdem und die tochter springt
gerne mal als souffleuse ein gemeinsam
mit musikerinnen 7
entwickeln sie einen abend zum thema
frau und frauenstimmrecht
[Musik]
mexiko ist nicht vorstellbar dass ist
zog sich dass meine tanne schön
gewachsen dass sich integrieren kann ja
scheint kursspitze sprach sie und quasi
als letzte aber was heißt das konkret
kiribati voraus ist und tadschikistan
und weist gleich was weiß ich es auch
nicht bewusst sei und dadurch gefundenes
fressen für aus borken wird darin wohl
aber mit sprache rhythmus und so schafft
rau diego klingt nach mit kleinen klären
mit ihrem programm erzählen die
performerinnen sogenannte erste ries
witzige bissiger und musikalisch
untermalte frauengeschichten die noch
nicht erzählt worden sind wirklich etwas
zum beispiel in anger die letzte frau
klappt nicht auf dem markt versteigert
worden nicht dass das schöne noch serie
aus ihrer biete war ein haus
[Musik]
mit 70 69 stellen oder andere
sechstagekrieges extra abstimmungskampf
lieber selbst anke sport lieber auf sexy
schlafen vor sechs uhr morgens bevor
weil sie die sexy cora die 420 spot mit
florian diesem land nicht besser bei mir
chrismon stimmrecht hatte mir überlegt
politik zwar ihre erste corolla
behelfsmäßig sterben einer wand zu tun
das haben der politik wenn der politik
die ganze zeit primetime aus im lande
suite war beträgt wird durch bakterien
können die politik mit einer pandemie
sei immer vorne dabei
wir werden durfte sie gewinne sich mit
der besten freundin
[Musik]
minute
sie ist eine neue leuchte figur für uns
frauen kamalla harris frischgebackene
vize präsidentin der usa
wir können nur erahnen welche kräfte sie
brauchte um diesen weg zu gehen aus frau
als nicht weiße frau und dabei erst noch
weiblich zu bleiben
ihr grosser moment kam ein herr es liegt
in alter von nun an ist sie
vizepräsidentin der usa die neue
mächtigste frau der welt
als erste schwarze erste person
indischen ursprungs und eben erste frau
perfekt getimt bis zu eben eine
biografie erschienen
wichtig der einfluss der mutter aus neu
delhi zum studium in die usa gekommen
wird sie eine anerkannte brustkrebs
expertin der vater ökonomieprofessor aus
jamaika beide engagieren sich in der
bürgerbewegung
als der vater die familie verlässt er
zieht die mutter kamera und ihre jüngere
schwester alleine zu selbstbewussten und
stolzen schwarzen frauen ihr leitsatz in
vielen dingen bist du die erste aber
sorge dafür dass du nicht die letzte
bist ich denke an sie und an die
generationen von frauen schwarzen
asiatischen weißen frauen latinas und
uhr einwohnerinnen amerikas die alle
entlang der geschichte unseres landes
den weg geebnet haben für diesen moment
heute abend
bei der feier des wahlsieges trägt sie
weiß zu ehren von 100 jahren wahlrecht
für frauen in den usa weiß die farbe der
ersten frauenbewegung
[Musik]
als tochter von akademikern ist kamera
harrys zwar privilegiert sie absolviert
aber die historisch afroamerikanische
howard university keine elite uni ihr
drang nach gerechtigkeit treibt sie auf
die straße gegen die apartheid in
südafrika
die biografie zeigt als bezirks und
später generalstaatsanwältin von
kalifornien empfiehlt sie sich bereits
für höhere aufgaben und sie begleitet
die erste trauung eines lesbischen
paares im rathaus von san francisco
entscheidend ihr nächster
karriereschritt senatorin für die
demokraten
so lernt die welt sie als hartnäckiger
befragen trump vertrauter kennen die
nicht locker lässt geht es in der
anhörung des kandidatin für den obersten
gerichtshof und das recht auf abtreibung
der nachwuchs soll es ihr gleichtun
so kostet sie briefe von kindern mit
fragen und kommentaren zur wahl
[Musik]
nun steht sie loyal an der seite von
präsident joe biden
gemeinsam sind sie personen des jahres
im time agassi kamera harris biografie
macht aber klar das ende auf der
karriereleiter ist das wohl noch nicht
sie hat gelernt auf ihren moment zu
warten
der dürfte früher oder später
[Musik]
ich habe allerdings die hand die
ausstellung kuratiert frauen ins
bundeshaushalt ganz felix sprechen für
mit einer erste politikerin
was ist für sie persönlich am
eindrücklichsten und metrik service
realisieren
wer ist hier eigentlich mit unerhörter
geschichte und zwar unerhört wirklich
doppelten sinn einer sitzt dass die
geschichte nicht kennt also die platte
bevölkerung es kommt wirklich nehmen ist
eine frau widerfahren ist im bundeshaus
und erhöht damit die frau immer wieder
ohne hat die sachen in die geschichte
können sie das fenster eines ewigkeit
treue ihres mandaten nationalrat die
nicht sie wollte ist sie zu unterlaufen
und des verbundes weber und ex sed stand
ihnen also mitnehmen
die eine ist von einer frau geklaut
worden ist was sind für sie eigentlich
grün das so ewig lang minister
schiedsfrau stimmrechten
es geht eigentlich ganz ganz viele
gründe glaubt dass auch lob ihre 4.3
endpunkt ist sicherlich das politische
system also mehr direkte demokratie
letztlich hat ohne jahr seien dafür
zuständig den abruf von bundesrat und
parlament welche vorwoche mit dem trio
stimmlich kultur der
föderalismuskommission ii die konturen
des bundes ab
ein zweiter punkt ist einer der sieben
fallen die politische notwendigkeit
schweiz hat sich immer wieder auch
spielt zelebriert vor uralter demokratie
diese regel modernisieren und die dem
zugestimmt aktivieren denn unser
kritisch als dritter punkt so froh
stimmt zu bewegen dass sie wenn die
frage sie unter dem strich dort musik
dies ist auch ein indem er eine
strategie was wird mit zu ermöglichen
und das hat nix verlust verursacht und
dann der letzte punkt war nie ganz
wichtig finden ist einfach die schweiz
sehr konstruktiv vorstellung von
geschlechter tourismus also spreche man
hätte die vorstellung es gibt andere
frau sie grundsätzlich unterschiedlich
innerste unterschiedliche bereiche offen
wenn die öffentliche hand machen sie
politik froh sind die fahrer und eine
legitimieren dass troja events gehören
und sie organisiert
die politik zu agieren was denken sie
was löst haben den news in der zukunft
frauen befürchtet sie gleich also wenn
man die solche gesuche genug zu jeder
krise besitze man situation oder ich
stelle mir fürchterlich irgendwie kupfer
und holz sieht man dass es sehr oft froh
sie war durch die übernahme war im home
office und zusätzlich noch die erfahrung
die arbeit von familie oder betreuung
von verschiedenen personen übernahme
insofern ist es verschiedentlich
sicherlich nicht förderlich
danke für das gespräch und werden um
ewig hören zu dem thema und vor dem
villinger am sonntag 7
die kollegen von der sternstunde
philosophie und zwar genau so rauschten
am 17
wie hast du stelle gefunden
also ja so sekunde das sind natürlich
große momente vor der frühschicht
festhalten wurde um eine frau zu
begegnen hat man natürlich auch spaß
macht mir genauso opfer da sind kaum
vereinigen was liebst du da geschrieben
und das heißt
und die hat in der goethestadt hat die
es geschafft
24 nationalrats und dadurch wenig für
die nächste woche da beschäftigen wir
uns mit der zunehmenden einsamkeit in
diesen zeiten ja und jetzt gleich auf
sf1 folgte serien meine geniale freundin
kommen sie gut durch die woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen ihr kultur es
los
[Musik]